on reste dans le monde de l'entreprise
et l'emploi bertrand de créer président
du medef yvelines présenté ses voeux le
17 janvier à l'hôtel de france à
versailles la cérémonie qui s'est
déroulée en présence de nombreux chefs
d'entreprises et d'élus a permis de
dresser un bilan de l'année 2016 et les
perspectives pour la nouvelle année 2010
est haussmann vendeurs d vous étiez sur
place
[Musique]
bertrand de créer l'année 2016 a été une
année difficile pour les entreprises
elles ont dû batailler notamment avec
les partenaires sociaux à cause de la
loi elle connerie et puis en 2017
il souhaite concentrer ses efforts sur
la formation écoutez le il est vrai
problème j'en ai parlé aussi sont des
problèmes de la formation
citoyens aujourd'hui je me fais mais
c'est l'apprentissage
parce que je crois que c'est une voie
qui aujourd'hui une voie d'excellence
il faut redonner corps des métiers qu'on
apprête à abandonner mais mais
le quasi plein emploi pour tous pour moi
c'est possible c'est électorale de 2010
est bertrand de créer l'a dit durant son
discours
le medef n'a pas vocation à soutenir des
partis politiques est content quand même
avoir du poids sur les prochaines
échéances
on aura des points et je le dis dans
discours
important des points clés
baisse des charges pour regagner des
marges de l'agilité l'investissement
un droit du travail
assouplies
une fiscalité assouplies et une
formation aussi et nous rencontrerons
pas personne ans avec des entrepreneurs
tous les candidats
alex législatif nous les rencontrerons
et nous discuterons avec eux pour leur
faire part de ce que nous voulons et ce
que nous croyons et cette volonté de
mettre le point sur la formation est
importante pour le président
d'initiatives saint quentin en yvelines
yves fouchet c'est un point important
pour aider les jeunes à la recherche
d'un emploi on parle du chômage et
notamment de celui des jeunes
la vérité c'est que la majorité des
jeunes chômeurs sont des chômeurs des
jeunes qui n'ont pas de formation
donc il est déterminant pour eux d'abord
parce que s'ils veulent trouver un job
de plus en plus de 2 de travaux
nécessitent un minimum de formation donc
pour eux d'abord et pour les entreprises
aussi parce que bon des métiers
historiquement dans la mécanique et
autres ont disparu et ne reviendront pas
mais donc il faut un minimum de
formation